we put out a call a few days ago on our
community tab on YouTube for people to
chime in with some questions so I was
going to read a few of that's okay oh
yes please
so this one comes in from rosemary
orange and rosemary writes when you
write a spec pilot how many episodes
should you have ready to go do you only
pitch the pilot yeah you only pitch the
pilot and look everything I say is
probably wrong I'm just going on my
experience right and because everybody
can be different and everybody there's
no nobody knows how showbiz works but
I'll give you what I think and what's
working for us we for Jack Johnson we
wrote a pilot and four other episodes
but everybody only wants to read the
pilot okay now we have outlines too for
the other four episodes but generally
speaking and it's great to have five
episodes founded of the sea extreme
example I think David Simon's wire he
had written every episode and he put
that on a story Bible and his extended
outlines but I think I think what you
need generally speaking and check this
with managers and agents because I don't
know sometimes I mean I'm not a manager
nation but a pilot is is the crucial
thing to have and then a one or two
sheet which gives it the concept of the
show which is you know you say you're
like with Jack Johnson we've got a it's
it's two pages it's jack on the cover
and then it's um it's God what's our cut
line
I'm Raging Bull meets somebody
but anyway so it's two page concept
sheet but the pilot we work and work and
work and work on now we've written for
other episodes written the whole
miniseries but we haven't what they seem
to want to see is the pilot this
two-page concept line and then also a
Raging Bull meets some rocky that makes
sense right so the pilot is our pilot is
a long title it's it's miniseries it's
actually a hundred twenty pages it's
probably
too long but yes see the pilot and then
have the other episodes if you've got
them done ready and but the pilot is
what everybody reads and then they're
going to also say you want it then we
want a sales deck when they get to that
we're actually compiling what's called a
sales deck now sales decks are
essentially at least as far as I can
tell about twenty or thirty PowerPoint
slides or if you're if you're smart and
you have a Mac they're what they're not
a PowerPoint anyway but they are
essentially two or three lines per deck
what this shows about who the market is
who the audience is for they're
generally for the producers sales team
with a sit around sort of brain data
from school what are we really going to
buy this well what is it what's it about
so it it breaks down this mini series
with what it's about who's it for who's
the audience gonna be that kind of thing
but maybe she just wait to do the sales
tech after you get your interest from
your manager an agent but basically a
pilot ok the pilots the real critical
thing to have and a concept sheet does
this sales deck have any graphics in it
or yes yeah yeah yeah I mean I'd show
you ours but I don't think I can you
know that's okay it's like 20 20 slides
it's you know first I'll give me to the
first lady Jack Johnson there he is and
then it's you know Muhammad Ali meets uh
no what did I say Raging Bull aging Bowl
meets rocky that's a slide you go to the
next slide you know he was the first
great african-american heavyweight in
history he broke all the rules right
each one of these is a slide so imagine
you're a production company and you're
like watching uh okay this is what we're
gonna buy ok that's really what it is
it's just like a sales deck like card
after card
you know this will break all the rules
you know this will give you the most
money it's a sales technique that's what
a sales deck is and it's designed to
give the production company an idea what
they're buying because they don't want
to read the pilot
lazy like oh okay I would read the pilot
asaji
just give this to Maya my person that
breaks this all down because I used to
be a story analyst a script reader and
this was used to be my job when someone
got interested in the project they'd go
okay well they sent us the pilot sounds
really good I brother to concept project
here Peter you read it and then I get
into a five-page who five pages man
that's all I can do that's that's what
that's what I did for for seven years
and I was a script reader which is a
great way to learn how to tell a movie
and television story because you
breaking it down and you're analyzed I
teach this at UCLA and at my own school
Peter Russell script doctor calm
that's Peter Russell script doctor calm
for all your story needs except you know
film courage too but yeah but I so I
teach a class on how to analyze script
and write what's called coverage so when
we send this thing out to production
companies they'll have their script
reader read the pilot and then they'll
synopsize it into a five page synopsis
and then they'll give comments
afterwards which are what are the
Bennett what are the good points of the
story what are the bad points this story
what's the potential development that's
what they do and so a lot of producers
who are good proofs I've worked for
fabulous geniuses like Brian Grazer and
les Moonves they will actually then read
the pilot lazy Bruce's will just go oh
okay oh well the coverage looks good
okay and we got a slot so let's let's
buy it or not so but that's why it's
critical for you as a beginning writer
to write the absolute best script you
can write it's it's so hard to break
into this business and there's no rules
now to do it except I have people ask me
Peter
so how do I get an agent how do I get a
manager right that's a question you get
asked all the time and I think the
greatest way to answer that is well why
don't you ask yourself how do I be good
okay how do I be a good writer because
if you become a good writer
then you can probably get an agent or a
manager okay so your product on the page
has to be amazing
okay that's how you attract interest no
beginning writer probably is going to
sell a concept you know Jack Johnson's a
great story but we have to write the
script you can't just go hey Jack
Johnson on the go yeah okay that's great
go ahead and write it when you're a
beginner you must write the script you
can't just get an agent based on a pitch
and and there's people that sell access
to producers and managers
I'm sure you've interviewed them they
say we're going to get you in the room
with a great producer we're gonna get
you the room with a great agent
yeah getting you in the room yes but
then you're gonna go here's my script
and they're gonna go okay it's no good
next right so getting you in the room
with someone is important as hell yes
I'm not minimizing that at all and it's
very difficult and a few years ago I
used to say well just shoot out your
script go to IMDB Pro and there'll be
emails for all the major production
houses there and they'll be general
emails they'll say not to send them to
send it anyway you know what all those
people are taking their emails off of
IMDB Pro there's no way to even get to
them I mean I I I used to work for a guy
who I loved and who loved me a big
Network guy who's now a big guy
somewhere else I wanted it I was like I
haven't talked to this nine years well I
got it his name's not even listed in the
I company like these guys are like Latin
American dictators Oh
tinted windows oh yeah I want to speak
to no one right
so even getting ahold of these people
now is insanely hard because I guess
they just get you know badgered all the
time so the best way to do it I know of
is to just be really good really really
good I am an I have an in because I go
speak at places I some I like a know
what I'm talking about
and as long as I get people
afterwards come after me see hey yeah
you sound great I'd like to see your
stuff I know that other people don't
have that so the best way I think is to
be is to have a super good script that's
rare by the way 99% of the time you will
see bad stories when you read a script
as a script reader I'd say and this is a
terrible statistic but people should
know 98% of the time when you read a
script and these are scripts that have
already gone through the process of a
big process of filtering they're going
to not be good because writing a good
script is insanely hard it's just it's
hot way harder than physics of brain
surgery way harder it's funny that you
mentioned just sort of this this
dropping off the script and thinking
that that's like the magical answer
because reading something about Michael
Crichton back in the day in the 90s and
he was living in this like very
unassuming place in Santa Monica which
I'm sure is not unassuming in price but
but he was sort of living in plain sight
as they said you know you wouldn't think
that he'd be there and because people
would just drop off he wanted to be sort
of unknown in the neighborhood because
he didn't want all these manuscripts
just put in his mailbox which was
happening so it's kind of interesting
that this theory of hey if I just know
this person I get this to them we're
good you know yes and I know that's
that's a great thing to have
pulsing in your heart because you need
that because that's the only way you're
gonna succeed but I would say to you you
say no Peter I've done all that all you
just can you just get me to the edge you
just get this to the agent this is it
I've got it
and I will say to them I would bet you
half my house that it is not good yet
you know you just please let me look at
it and tell you because I'll bet you
it's not good yet and and I that's a
terrible thing but it's look I spent 20
years before my stuff is anywhere near
I've got so much respect for a writer
that can sit down and knock off a great
script I've heard that that's possible
there's one writer he works for American
crime now who apparently just went to a
coffee shop one day and said and he's a
he was a calming stamp I'm gonna write a
script he wrote a script any soul he was
great
he's like Shakespeare but 99.9% of the
people I know in the business that are
very good very talented they didn't do
it that way they spent years before it
got good it's sort of like saying hey I
think I could do stand-up but I don't
want to go and do all the five years for
it gave me the Comedy Store I'm gonna do
it tonight you know and I know that I'm
so good I've never done it but I know
I'm so good that all that well no yeah
yeah no probably not probably not gonna
do that
you